Sex Magic is utilizing your sexual
energy for magic whether that's for
healing or amplifying your personal
power or creating a dream actualizing a
vision well I've done this practice in
every position I've done it I've done it
standing I've done it with two hands
I've done it with one hand I've seen
people do all kinds of things doing this
practice when you're calling something
in from a state of pleasure I mean the
universe wouldn't make orgasms feel so
good if it didn't like us having them
the first time I ever did that practice
with sisters in a circle it was so
profoundly healing to let it be
acceptable to be heard and to hear
someone else
hey girlfriend what you doing tonight
um so I was wondering
exactly but every Sunday morning we
would do Sex Magic and brunch